sie sind wohl die umstrittensten
Popstars-Gewinner seit die Castingshow
existiert laviv im Internet wird die
Band Zusammensetzung heißt diskutiert
und im Popstar Steam scheint es jemanden
gegeben zu haben der nicht nur ihr
Bestes wollte ein Video das offenbar
unter Verschluss gehalten werden sollte
geriet ins Netz zwar ließ es die
Plattenfirma sperren doch es wurde
kopiert und wieder hochgeladen dort sind
nicht die Gewinnerin Katrin sondern die
ausgeschiedene Esra Bayern
Bandmitglied Julia erklärt in der
online-talkshow klicksum.de die
missliche Lage wir haben das Video von
Esra auf Youtube natürlich auch gesehen
das heißt ja da äh la wie featuring Esra
also erstmal dazu laviv besteht aus
Katrin Michael Sarah und mir und nicht
nur aus uns dreien featuring jemanden
von daher ist dieses Video für mich
schon mal unnütz zweitens das Video ist
ins Netz gekommen weil jemand den
Maulwurf gespielt hat und was Falsches
gemacht hat und es wird niemals ein
laviv featuring Esra oder la viv
Mitesser geben weil wir wurden so von
euch gewählt und ich meine wir wissen
alle dass Esra sehr viele Fans hat aber
wenn Esra mehr Fans hätte als Katrin
wäre sie jetzt in der Band von daher ihr
lieben Leute habt uns so gewählt und ähm
ja lavif ist vollständig und leider ohne
Essen aber wir haben die liebe Katrin
dabei und das ist ganz gut so